son varias las claves a tener en cuenta
para la definición de esta elección una
de ellas es como decíamos la
participación y sobre todo entre la
población árabe que representa el 17%
del padrón en este sector El más
empobrecido y violentado de la sociedad
de israelí ha reinado al menos en la
previa mayormente la apatía después
sobre todo de la desilusión de que tras
tener un partido árabe en la coalición
de gobierno no haya esto no haya
significado grandes mejoras en su
calidad de vida el otro gran afecto es
el ascenso de la extrema derecha
representada en sionismo religioso una
alianza de tres partidos cuya principal
figura es el parlamentario y tomar
bengivir quien se ha caracterizado por
sus posturas racistas y antiárabes por
poner un ejemplo en el pasado ha llamado
a deportar a aquellos ciudadanos árabes
israelíes que no sean leales al Estado
de Israel el Otro aspecto a tener en
cuenta es el resultado de la izquierda
una fuerza fundacional desde el inicio
del estado de Israel pero que se
enfrenta posiblemente a su peor
resultado electoral y luchando por pasar
ese umbral del 3,25% de los votos tanto
el resultado de la izquierda como el
resultado de los partidos árabes puede
ser determinante para definir si se
rompe el estancamiento político en favor
Ya sea o del ex Primer Ministro benjahu
o del actual Primer Ministro Jack lapid
o si en cambio se mantiene este
estancamiento lo cual no se llevaría a
una nueva elección posiblemente en mayo
de 2023